good morning John so I haven't been
super secretive about the fact that I've
been writing a book a novel like book
but I haven't really broadcasted it
either
starting in the NaNoWriMo times of
November I started writing it during the
month of November I got to 15,000 words
and now as of June 26th I can confirm
that I have hit the 50,000 word
NaNoWriMo mark and I am not at all
disappointed in my slowness well with
the tripod with money the problem is
that the book is not anywhere close to
being done turns out a lot of books are
much longer than 50,000 words in fact
some of my favorites are like four or
five hundred thousand words so if I do
this and you include revisions I'll
probably be still reading this book at
least a year from now which is
terrifying I have no reason to believe
that I will be able to do this it's
nothing like anything I've ever done
before in it's difficult and it's
massive in scale and worst of all though
this could also be considered an asset I
have this brother who is not only a very
successful writer but he's a very good
writer which is intimidating though stop
being so talented but I was in the
shower this morning and I was thinking
about what we mean would we say that
someone is good at something like good
mathematician or a good writer or a good
computer programmer there are two ways
to imagine that one is that the person
and their skill is a snapshot that
somehow stretches both forward and
backward in time infinitely which makes
no sense but happens to be the way that
I usually think about people who were
really skilled at stuff the easiest and
most common way to imagine skill is to
imagine that you're just born with it
the other way to imagine skill and
talent is that while there may be some
innate traits that make the acquisition
of those skills and talents more easily
it's a continuum and everybody starts
out bad and can work toward getting good
psychologist Carol Dweck has been
studying the differences between these
two mindsets for over 30 years she calls
the mindset that skills and talents are
innate the fixed mindset and the
alternative that skills and talents are
acquired is the growth mindset now there
are two main advantages to the growth
mindset one is that it is the correct
one it is a much truer reflection of
reality than the fixed mindset no one is
born good at math
no one is born a good writer we aren't
even born capable of abstract thought or
communication the fact that I can have a
thought inside of my head and then make
these like tiny little carefully
constructed subtle sounds with my mouth
and then you can hear those sounds and
then understand what I'm talking about
that is a skill that took us both lots
of time to master and I honestly feel
like I'm still getting better at that
skill as a guy who talks a lot I'm
better at it now than I used to be
before I started to be a professional
speaker at camera the other advantage of
the growth mindset is that people who
have it show a measurable increase in
their ability to acquire new skill
because it turns out if you get stuck
with the idea that all skill is innate
and that people are good at stuff
because they're good at stuff and bad at
stuff because they're bad at stuff then
you never get good at stuff because
everybody starts out bad as far as I can
tell this is the main trick to getting
good at stuff II ultimate first step is
to just realize that skill and talent
are not innate that all of these things
come from hard work and that they are
composed of a multitude of different
things like self-control and empathy and
like just building and reinforcing
neural pathways over and over and over
again and that those are all things that
psychology has proven are malleable we
can build those skills we can change
those things about ourselves and the
only way to write a good book is
probably to write a bad one and look at
it and think of all the reasons why it's
bad and then make it good so I got to do
that it's gonna take a lot of time but
I'm gonna do the thing you guys have got
to do the thing John stopped writing so
I can catch up and I'll see you on
Tuesday don't stop writing